I think there's two times the door to
the subconscious mind opens up when we
wake up in the morning and we go to bed
at night and it's simple brain chemistry
and simple physiology we have a
circadian rhythm as soon as there's
light our body has been pretty much
programmed that we begin to release
serotonin different chemicals that kind
of wake us up so our brain waves go from
Delta to Theta to Alpha to Beta and we
kind of slide up this way and then
you're back to conscious awareness local
in space and time when you go to bed at
night you go from beta to Alpha to Theta
to Delta and you slide down now if
you're stressed you can't stop thinking
you stay in beta you're thinking
actually is arousing the body because
you're thinking about your problems you
can't slide down those two points in the
day when we wake up in the morning go to
bed at night when we're and when alpha
or our analytical facilities are
suppressed we're in Theta we're in a
hypnotic State and the door between the
conscious mind on the subconscious mind
is wide open what separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious
mind is the analytical mind so as you
suppress analytical facilities you can
program anybody to do any thing hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggled
to stay afloat I quit I'm a business
partner and the thing that kept me
motivated kept me going was studying the
stories of famous successful
entrepreneurs and in their stories it
gave me the hope the drive the ambition
the thinking that maybe I can do it too
that extra bit of belief and I still
need their stories today and I'm honored
to share them with you here as well so
today let's get some incredible lessons
from the one and only Joe with espenza
enjoy
what really happens for most people
before they even reach for their cell
phone and by the way the statistics are
86 of the people in the western world
first thing first thing they do is they
reach for the cell phone and they
connect to everything that's known and
why is that a problem
well I would never tell people how to
think but I would give them information
to cause them to think so the device is
reminding them
of things that are known and every
person every object everything every
place is mapped neurologically in our
brain because we've experienced it and
then we have an emotion associated with
our co-worker with our boss with our ex
with our whoever and so the moment we
start responding
now we start feeling the same way
so now the environment
is actually controlling the person's
feelings and thoughts yeah and anything
that controls the way we feel in the way
we think we're victims too
so something's programming us to think
and feel a certain way there's nothing
wrong with that you can you should check
your tax but and do whatever you need to
do but the first thing in the morning if
the door between the conscious mind the
subconscious mind is open
why don't we program a new Behavior why
don't we rehearse a different way of
being with our children with our spouse
in our Zoom meetings when we're alone
when we're in traffic is there a better
way to evolve our experience so if
you're truly in the game of evolution
you're truly in the game like one
lifetime one day what am I working on
today can I respond different way to
this person can I think this way instead
of that way let me be conscious of my
unconscious thoughts let me not be in a
habit let me stay away from certain
emotions let me practice feeling these
emotions see if I can maintain it now
you're in the game you're out of the
bleachers and you're on the playing
field so
it actually happens even before the cell
phone because what most people do is
they wake up and the first thing they do
is the brain is a record of the past
they think other problems and those
problems are just memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people and objects at certain
times and places the moment they think
of their problems they're thinking in
the past then when they think about
their problems and they feel unhappy now
their bodies in the past and if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny yeah
wow and then the emotion that's
associated is now the bodies in the past
because thoughts of the language of the
brain feelings of the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being now here's
the problem
if you can't think
greater than how you feel
and you believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny and
you understand that feelings and
emotions a record of the past
then you're thinking in the past and
your life
will stay the same rule number two is
rewire your brain most people try to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work we
literally have to become someone else in
other words thoughts are the language of
the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how you think and how you feel
creates a state of being so most people
have experiences in their life that
brand them emotionally they feel fear
they feel anger they fear bitterness
they feel frustration they feel
insecurity
and those emotions then become part of
their identity so once they think
certain thoughts that turn on certain
circuits in their brain that are equal
to their insecurity and then they feel
insecure the moment they feel insecure
they think more insecure thoughts which
makes more chemicals for them to feel
insecure
and the repetition of that cycle over
time conditions the body to
subconsciously become the mind of
insecurity
so then the person says I am insecure
and whenever you say I am anything
you're commanding your mind and body
towards a destiny so then most peoples
biology is for the most part their past
and so if you're not being defined by
the vision of the future some new
possibility in your life you're only
left with the old circuitry in your
brain and the old emotions of the past
so the question then is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the experience has already
occurred now the latest research in
Neuroscience says you can change your
brain just by thinking
so then as you begin to think about a
new possibility and your brain begins to
fire in new sequences and new patterns
and new combinations and you begin to
plan your behaviors and you begin to
review in your mind mentally rehearse
who you're going to be in your life the
mere action of mental rehearsal begins
to install the neurological circuits in
your brain now your brain is no longer a
record of the past
now it's in fact a map to the Future
and if you were then to begin to
emotionally embrace your future before
it's made manifest in other words
you're not waiting for your healing to
feel wholeness you're not waiting for
your new relationship to feel love
you're not waiting for the mystical
moment to feel awe you're not waiting
for your success to feel empowered
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect in other words
the materialist
the person who's waiting for their
wealth to come to feel abundance
uh they're living by that model of cause
and effect but the quantum model is
about causing an effect which means you
begin to experience your own worthiness
and your abundance before it occurs you
have to feel wholeness in order for your
healing to occur
we have to feel love for ourselves and
love for life in order for us to have
love in our life and so then to instruct
people how to teach their body
emotionally how that future could feel
like before it's made manifest
if they do it properly their body is the
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're beginning to
Signal new genes in new ways that begins
to change their body to look like the
event has already occurred so the
process of change
and the meditative model requires
unlearning and relearning requires
breaking the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self
we'll be saying Neuroscience pruning
synaptic connections and sprouting new
connections unfiring and unwiring and
re-firing and rewiring
unmemorizing emotions that are stored in
the body and then reconditioning the
body to a new mind into a new motion no
longer signaling the same genes in the
same way but signaling new genes in new
ways
beginning to pull your energy out of the
past and beginning to invest your energy
into the future rule number three is
control your thoughts the majority of
the thoughts that we think every single
day are the same thoughts as we thought
yesterday
and in fact ninety percent of them are
and the same thoughts leading to the
same choices the same choices leading to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
creating the same experiences and the
same experiences producing the same
feelings and emotions
begins to cause our biology
to become very similar very same and
the repetition of that and firing and
wiring then creates automatic programs
in the brain and body and 95 percent of
who we are is a state of unconscious or
subconscious programs where we've done
something so many times that the body
now can actually do it automatically
without the conscious mind so then if
you truly wanted to change and you
understood that your personality creates
your personal reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think how you act and how you feel
and the present personality who's
listening to this call has created the
present personal reality called their
life that means if they wanted to create
a new personal reality a new life they
would have to begin to change their
personality they'd have to change
themselves and most people then try to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality it doesn't work
so then if you're sitting in your
meditation and you ask yourself the
question who do I want to be when I open
my eyes what is the greatest expression
of myself
and you said okay let me remind myself
of how I no longer want to think
you know the thoughts like
whatever it's too hard I'll never change
I'll never get what I want let me become
so conscious
of those unconscious thoughts that I
wouldn't let that thought slit by my
awareness today unnoticed by me and
program my autonomic nervous system in
the specific outcome
none of you said how would I want to
speak today
how do I want to act how do I want to
behave and you reminded yourself how you
weren't going to act and how you weren't
going to behave and you became conscious
of those unconscious habits to such a
degree you wouldn't go unconscious and
behave in the same way that's when
you're no longer the program now your
Consciousness observing the program if
you said when is my energy drop when
when what do I feel when I feel those
typical familiar emotions what are they
uh so let me name them just so I'm so
aware of them that when my energy drops
I can catch myself
in that moment and not return back to
the same familiar emotions
and cause my body to believe it's back
in the past and we can't see a new
future from the past so that process
then
is what I call getting beyond the old
self and it's a disentangling from the
program the word meditation means to
become familiar with so as you sit there
and become familiar with those states of
Mind and Body you begin to objectify
your subjective self now now you are you
are becoming so aware of the unconscious
programs you won't go unconscious and
that's the first step to change and then
what if you said what thoughts do I want
to fire and wire in my brain what
thoughts do I want to put my attention
behind and begin to install the new
circuitry the new hardware and if I keep
my attention on it and I fire and wire
those thoughts it's going to begin to
become a software program and that's
going to be the new voice in my head
that's going to be the voice that's
telling me a new program that you can
that it is possible also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is learn to
unlearn you're gonna go out into life
and try it out okay I've changed my
internal State you could have a great
meditation you can connect your heart
could open this happen to me you can
open your heart you'll be amazing you'll
feel like a day is invincible and you
get up and then the rest of your day
you're unconscious of the 15 hours of
your day so you're going to wait one
hour
of being in a different state of being
against 15 hours of you being unhappy
and rushing and in a program so then
how many times
do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's called change how
many times do we have to go unconscious
to the point where we no longer go
unconscious and we stay conscious that's
the moment of change now if you're truly
out of the bleachers and you're on the
playing field and this happens to a lot
of people in our work they say you know
I really believe that this is the truth
I really believe that you could heal
yourself I really believe you could
change your life I've seen the
testimonials
I just never believed that it could
happen to me now this is a big moment
now you're really stepping on the
playing field so
a person who starts doing their work
they're not they're not interested in
healing the true the person who's truly
interested in this work they understand
that the only way they can heal
is that they have to change
they're not saying I'm going to wait for
my wealth or my healing to happen in
order for me to feel grateful and be
joyful in life they're saying I feel
grateful my healing is going to begin
right if I if I feel more whole then
there should be some change in my gene
expression so they've studied the
content they've studied the information
and now it becomes extremely practical
so they may have a great meditation
we've seen this happen to many people
they sleep better
they have less pain they have more
energy but their blood values never
change
now they don't say oh
I feel better but I'm failing this
doesn't work they say what is it about
me
that's stopping this from completely
healing okay how am I
in my waking day the moment you begin to
ask that question you turn on the
frontal lobe and the frontal lobe is the
seat of your conscience now the moment
you start looking at at the end of your
day how did I do this is such an
important question how'd I do today did
I fall from grace when did I lose it and
who did I lose it with I had another
opportunity how would I do it
differently they'll tell you I've seen
them stand on the stage and tell their
story and say
I had to start really watching myself in
my life how I was emotionally responding
to my ex how I was emotionally
responding to my financial problems I
had to really really pay attention that
and that takes an enormous amount of
energy
and an enormous amount of awareness to
stop the program right so you forget and
you go damn I went unconsciously now you
didn't lose you didn't fail
he just became conscious now if you keep
becoming so conscious of your
unconscious States you're you're outside
the program you're only in the program
when you're unconscious the moment
you're conscious you can objectify your
subjective self so you can see yourself
Through The Eyes of someone else so the
learning process comes from the mistake
the brain learns by mistakes and
surprises I've made enough of them in my
life it's just whether you're going to
do it again yeah you want to do it again
you're back in the habit back in the
routine if you say this is it the next
time that happens I am not going to do
that not for anybody else
but because those emotions actually my
response to that person or that
circumstance is actually weakening the
organism is that person that
circumstance worth it so then
it's Evolution it's Evolution the
challenge then has to be met with a
greater level of mind now if you're just
doing your meditation just because you
want to please God or do the right thing
or feel good about yourself that's going
to get stale after a while because it's
just going to become another routine
between your coffee and your shower and
your emails and your drive to work and
people aren't present right so so the
familiar past conditioning is based on
the past that thought and the feeling
but habituation is the programming them
to predictable future that's the known
so if you teach a person how to find the
present moment that's where the unknown
exists and that takes that takes a lot
of energy and a lot of awareness and yet
if you practice it the body literally
will begin to respond to the mind it's
like training an animal it finally
relaxes and when that occurs your
response to people and circumstances in
your life will be different because you
overcame yourself at the beginning of
the day rule number five is improve your
awareness I've believe that your
personality creates your personal
reality
and in order to change your personal
reality your life it means then that on
some level we have to change because
nothing changes in our life unless we
change
so if people have understand that 90 of
the thoughts that they think every day
are the same thoughts as the day before
that's that's a fact and the same
thoughts always lead to the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences
and the same experiences produce the
very same feelings and emotions and
those same emotions influence our very
same thoughts and our biology our
circuitry our neurochemistry our
hormones our gene expression stays the
same
because we're the same
but the repetition of firing and wiring
the same circuits in our brain in the
same way
causes us to create a very finite set of
circuitry that becomes our identity and
our personality and nerve cells that
fire together wire together which means
you keep doing it it gets easier for
them to fire and they run more
automatically
so it turns out 95 percent of Who We Are
by our midlife is a set of memorized uh
behaviors unconscious habits hardwired
thoughts and attitudes
conditioned emotions that are so
familiar to us that it doesn't even feel
like uh fear or it doesn't feel like
sadness is just who we are
so it usually takes crisis or trauma or
disease or diagnosis or lowest point in
your life where you're knocked to your
knees
and for that moment
you actually have a view of yourself
outside of yourself you can see yourself
from a different state that the facade
the the the the the whole illusion is
over and that's when a person really
begins to think about what they've been
thinking about they begin to notice how
they speak or how they act
and I think they begin to pay attention
to those feelings uh on a more regular
unconscious basis and the word
meditation I look this up because when I
started my journey I'm I'm very
scientifically minded the word
meditation the symbol means to become
familiar with
so
so then the first step to change if you
wanted to create a new life you have to
change it to change your personal
reality you have to change your
personality and the first step is
consciousness or becoming aware so the
moment you become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts the moment you
become aware of your automatic reflexive
habits and and your emotional reactions
the moment you can become so conscious
of those unconscious states of mind and
body
that you don't go unconscious again so
familiar with those States and how many
times do we have to forget or go
unconscious till we no longer forget or
go unconscious and we stay conscious
that's that's that's us lighting a match
in a dark place and most people when
they do meditation they they actually
think when those voices come up and when
the chatter starts and those emotions
start
they actually think that they're doing
their meditation wrong
and I want them to know that they're
actually doing it right because you're
coming up against those thoughts that
slip by your awareness unnoticed or
unchecked by many people uh you all of a
sudden catch how you speak and people
say if I really want to be happy let's
think about this
I don't wanna I don't wanna complain I
don't want to blame I don't want to make
excuses I don't want to feel sorry for
myself I'm going to stop that now that's
breaking a habit of being yourself
that's a that takes a lot of energy and
a lot of awareness and and and our
environment then the circumstances our
environment are always available for us
to think and feel equal to everything in
our life you know so the environment for
many people as we said earlier controls
the way they think and feel so when they
respond to their co-worker when they
respond to the news when they respond to
the
um the the traffic in their life
uh that response causes them to return
back to those unconscious programs so
but sitting in a meditation and really
sitting in the fire and
believing that there's something on the
other side of that thought uh believing
that there's something on the other side
of some Behavior or some emotion that
feel makes us feel a certain way that's
that's stepping into the unknown and and
it takes
um
it takes us disconnecting from the
environment that's what meditation is
about playing music or hearing nothing
or closing your eyes and not eating not
smelling not tasting not feeling with
your body you're putting your body away
and you're not letting it be the mind or
the program you're making it sit still
you're training the animal right and and
a person starts feeling emotional and
they catch themselves
starting to feel those emotions instead
of letting that emotion Drive certain
thoughts or actions
that person settles the body down
uh in the meditation and brings it back
into the present moment and that's a
victory angle number six the last one
before some very special bonus clips
change your story
how would an abundant person think write
it down dude and fire and why are those
thoughts in your brain and install the
hardware keep doing it with attention
and intention it becomes the new voice
in your head it becomes a software
program then say okay
how am I going to be in my life today
what would an abundant person how would
they behave and before you reach for
your cell phone and start scrolling
through your social media close your
eyes and rehearse in your mind how that
person would walk how they would Breathe
how they would smile how they would
greet people how they would be on Zoom
calls how would they be in traffic how
would they be at dinner
and and the act of closing your eyes and
mentally rehearsing the ACT if you're
truly present
the brain does not know the difference
between the real life experience and
what you're imagining in fact just a
little bit of time you start to install
the neurological Hardware to look like
you already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past it's primed
for the future keep doing it keep
rehearsing no different than playing an
instrument no different than learning
how to dance no different on learning
how to act or play a sport everybody's
always rehearsing right the rehearsal
process
changes the brain to look like you've
already done it you've already
experienced it now what's the essential
part of that the hardware is in place
now all you got to do is step into the
footprint keep doing it it becomes a
software program you start acting like
an abundant person everything changes
your energy changes your mood changes
the way you walk we breathe your posture
changes you're out of the known right
you've got to condition the body now
emotionally into the future
can't open your eyes in the morning
until you are feeling worthy to receive
and if you can't feel worthy to receive
then if not now when if it takes you two
hours to get there ask me if it's worth
30 years
of running trying to get what you need
matter to matter
okay so then the person who wrestles
with their lack they're out of the
bleachers
and they're on the playing field but
here's what we learned here's what we
learned let's go back to beliefs now so
remember belief is just the thought you
keep thinking over and over again a
belief is something that you keep
thinking enough times that you hardwired
in your brain and it becomes an
automatic program and we have beliefs
about all kinds of things money
relationships God whatever it is it's
all based on what we've been told or our
past experiences right
the boundaries of those beliefs are our
emotions right so let's just say you got
betrayed or somebody abused you or your
father told you that money was bad and
there's never enough of it or whatever
that's a story okay but but somehow it
left an impression on you remember that
event very clearly and that's kind of
rooted in who you are right
okay so that emotion then is the
boundary of our belief Okay so
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being if you take a
thought and a feeling a thought and a
feeling of thought and a feeling of
thought and a feeling it's called an
attitude yes there's a good thoughts
with a series of Good Feelings you say I
have a good attitude today in a series
of negative thoughts that are connected
to a series of negative feelings you say
I'm a bad attitude today so attitudes
are just shortened states of being good
attitude in the morning bad attitude in
the afternoon if you take an attitude
and attitude and attitude keep those up
any string attitudes together you create
what's called a belief and a belief is
just an extended state of being so if
you keep thinking the same thought you
keep hard wiring in the brain you keep
feeling the same feeling you keep
conditioning in your body the redundancy
of that cycle over and over again
conditions the body to subconsciously
become the mind of that belief and all
beliefs
our subconscious states of being okay
I think a belief a belief a belief in
your string them together you form
what's called a perception and
perceptions are just such extended
states of being
that we're unconscious and so then we we
edit out reality in fact most people
don't see things the way they are they
see things the way they are right and
people are always filling in reality
unconsciously based on their memory they
could be married to a person for 40
years and they don't see the person they
see the memory of the person right and
there's research to prove this okay so
how do we change the belief or
perception about herself or our lives
okay we've studied this
okay let's just say that lack is
ingrained in there you got the story you
lived on the streets you lost everything
you got betrayed your business partner
took everything took your wife took you
got the story in the half okay okay you
got to start telling the new story of
the future right you got to believe in
that future more than you have to
believe in the past so how do you do
that you only believe in the past when
you feel the emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
of the future right okay so in order for
us to change a belief or perception
about ourself and our lives
we have to make a decision
with such firm intention
the amplitude of that decision carries a
level of energy
that's greater than the hardwired
programs in your brain and the emotional
condition in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we down
regulate that old belief if the trauma
created an emotional quotient of sex
or seven then your decision to change
your beliefs got to be a nine right and
you got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
because you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created with some
strong emotion right but at the
amplitude of that emotion is greater
than the Betrayal Boom the body starts
responding to mind and
you're actually giving your body a taste
of the future emotionally so you brand
your voice possible no your body's
actually getting the taste of that
future event experiencing the future now
exactly big explosion on the quantum
field big explosion so the side effect
of that
is if you combine that clear intention
with that elevated emotion you're
basically remembering your future and it
looks no different than remembering your
past think neurologically within the
circuits of that memory and feel within
the emotions of that new belief and
watch your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change it when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lacking or lack our separation
it's about change so then when we
finally realize in order for us
to become abundant
we have to overcome the old personality
and that's 95 percent of who we are
right yes so then
the side effect of the beginning of this
process
is a lot of discomfort it is a lot of
discomfort because you're stepping
outside the known into the unknown and
now you can't predict it's scary no
you'd rather hold on to your lack the
pain and suffering rather tell the story
of that at least it makes you feel
something that's familiar when you step
outside and you're saying I'm not going
to complain about money any longer I'm
not going to point about I don't have
any I'm not going to judge other people
who do I'm not going to say I can I'm
not worthy it's never going to work all
those things got to go I'm not going to
feel lack I'm not going to feel unworthy
I'm not going to feel separation I'm not
going to feel resentment these are the
things that are keeping my reality the
same now it's no longer about abundance
about who you become
so the overcoming process becomes the
becoming process and so many people
come to this work they want abundance
they want healing they want a new
relationship they want a new career they
want the mystical but really they want
wholeness and and the one healing they
want peace they want wholeness because
they feel on whole well well when you're
in lack or you're in separation you're
not home imagine feeling so much
wholeness that's impossible to want
that's what our that's what we're
working on with people then you can
really enjoy a sunset then you can
really enjoy a meal and you can really
enjoy your friends you can I I I
talk to people that are very abundant I
mean in the billions abundant and you
know
so many of them say we are in misery
because in our whole we're in agony
because they can enjoy life anymore
that's what they want I mean people want
abundance to be able to enjoy life they
want to be able to do whatever they want
with whoever they want as many times as
they want whatever they want that's
Freedom right or people want a bun
that's the sponsoring thought is really
they want freedom right or whatever
their sponsoring thought would be
there's two really paradigms two
specific paradigms of reality and
that are about what's called Newtonian
physics which is cause and effect that
you know something happens to us in our
environment but the experience happens
it changes us internally and then we
react to that condition and when we
react to the condition we begin to
function at a fat of something outside
of us if something good happens to us
and we react positively then we give
thanks after the experience happens
really but either way we're pretty much
victims of Destiny
Quantum model of reality says that mind
and matter aren't separate like that
that subjective mind somehow has an
effect on the enchanted world so then
if you begin to piece this together
you can have a clear intention of what
you want
but then to move into the state of how
you would feel if it already happened
gratitude is an emotional signature that
the event is already done so if you can
teach your body emotionally what it
feels like
to have the event already happen and you
can get in touch with that then your
body is the unconscious mind doesn't
know the difference between the
experience that produces the emotion and
the emotion that you fabricate or create
by thought alone and when we move into a
state of being where mind and body are
working together are our thoughts and
feelings are aligned there are
biological changes that happen in the
brain and body and we move into that
state of being and when we're in that
state of being the universe begins to
organize itself to reflect a new state
of being we have such great evidence to
show that there's something very
profound that happens
when a person has a transcendental
moment and they have an interaction with
energy when they hit those elegant
States
they sometimes come to events as sick
we draw their blood at the beginning of
the event their event and they we see
the what happens to their brain we see
what happens to their heart and we know
this person has had a profound moment
and we draw their blood and we measure
everything afterwards
if we take the plasma of those
individuals
as an example and we take a pseudovirus
that looks just like SARS cov2
or we actually take now recently we
actually did the actual SARS virus and
we put that virus
in the presence of that person that
advanced meditator that had that
transcendental moment
there's a consistent resistance to the
virus the virus cannot enter the cell of
that person
in people that are novice meditators and
they come to a week-long event some of
the virus enters their cells some of the
virus stays out so there's somewhat of
an immunity in all the controls they get
infected
all right so we know now that there's
some agent some cofactor in the blood
when a person has this moment
so we've gone through some extensive
scientific studies and we actually
isolated the very protein
that stops the virus from entering the
cell
and if we take that protein
and we put it in the infected plasma of
the controls
all of the infected controls become
uninfected now we're not getting that
from anywhere out there we're actually
finding it in someone
who has had a moment where they've
interacted with Oneness with wholeness
and whether it's there's some change in
energy in the blood and there's some
proteins being released but we're
starting to discover there's some
powerful agents when this occurs take
the blood of that advanced meditator and
put it
take their plasma and put it in a
uterine cancer cell and and the cancer
cells the mitochondria the powerhouses
of the cells are switched on and they're
pumping out a lot of energy that's why
they're almost Immortal if we take the
blood of the advanced meditator and we
subject to a uterine cancer cell 75 of
the energy
comes out of the mitochondria it takes
that wind out of the cells
take the plasma of that at the same
advanced meditator
and put it on a neuron that has
Alzheimer's and produces the amyloid
protein and there's a significant change
in the gene expression of the
Alzheimer's Gene
take that person then and subject their
blood to the variance
the Lambda variant the Delta variant the
beta variance and the same thing occurs
they're resistant
uh to the virus now what does that mean
okay
if you really think about this
it would suggest
that there's very dramatic environmental
changes taking place from a scientific
standpoint anybody who sees this kind of
gene expression change or change in
biology they would say oh my God that
suggests that there's a dramatic change
in the environment the problem is is the
person is sitting in a ballroom in a
hotel there's not a lot a lot of things
going on in a ballroom in a hotel it's
not a changing environment where is all
that change coming from
information from the field so we have
great great testimony in our community
of people that have reversed all kinds
of things and people have created all
kinds of wealth and created all kinds of
mystical moments
and we have really great evidence
in our scientific studies and evidences
the loudest voice it is the voice that
makes the biggest difference
so
what kind of human being then
who has trained themselves
to no longer be victim to their
environment if I said to you Emilio why
what's up with you today and you say I'm
sad because of this person or this
circumstance I would say oh we mean that
person or that circumstance is
controlling the way you feel and the way
you think well anything that's
you think you're victim to
so then when things are good you feel
good when things are bad you feel bad
right and if you feel bad then you look
for something out there to make this
feeling go away but then when the when
the novelty or the event is over here
comes that feeling again and you got to
go chase something else well
the response for many people to their
environment is actually weakening their
body the stress response they react to
some event and their reaction to the
event is actually weakening the organism
now short term it's cool all organisms
can handle that but the long-term
effects of that just diminishes or taps
the body's resources of vital energy
there's no energy to heal there's no
energy for growth and repair so what
we're suggesting
is that when the person becomes less
victim to their environment and
realizing that they're more love the
creator of their environment and they're
less their response to the environment
weakens them less
because they know how to self-regulate
and change
they'll be less susceptible to things in
their environment large or small and
creating a life
that is Meaningful for a person someone
as young as you
and you start seeing that you're
actually creating it
you every time you get feedback of
breadcrumb from the universe saying
Emilio keep going keep your keep your
head down keep going you're running
gonna run into something big all of
those things are convincing you that you
are not
the victim to your life that you're
actually the creator of your life and
people who actually do this not that you
react the question is how long you react
and teaching people how to move out of
those States
and back into homeostasis back into
balance by self-regulating with their
eyes open getting so good at doing it in
their meditation with their eyes closed
that they could actually do it with
their eyes open in their life now it's a
different game so
get enough people
in the world becoming less reactive to
their environment they're less
controlled by their environment and the
side effect of that is there's a huge
change in our biology huge I can I could
say right now with certainty I can say
that if people commit
to say as an example seven days of of an
event that we do I can say there will be
so many biological changes that take
place in the body we have the evidence
that says that uh but we have such a
profound hope
for Humanity in what we're discovering
we really think that you know
everything's going to be handed to us or
we can get whatever we want nothing's
wrong with that that's really cool
that's really great but in the creative
process
um you actually have to get outside of
time
in order for you to be able to create
because if you're trying to predict
what's going to happen in the next
moment if you keep Romancing what
happens you're not in the present moment
The Familiar past is the known the
predictable future is the known
the present moment is the unknown that
is where all possibilities exist so yes
there is a function of three-dimensional
reality and Technology where more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time certainly there's some type of
energetic thing that's taking place in
so many ways and to me that energy is
actually endorsing whoever you want to
be that's what I believe so if you want
to be a victim get ready because it's
going to get really good for you because
that energy is more available if you
want to heal wow there's a lot of people
healing now and they're using that
energy instrumentally in a positive way
so so yes there's a quickening that's
taking place and it's creating quite a
contrast or extremes that are taking
place in reality and the more extreme it
gets the more unstable the system right
so uh governments
um
journalism
education religion medicine
uh everything's kind of falling apart
you know um uh and and it's very obvious
to people that has to happen for a new
Consciousness to emerge the thing is
we can't face these changes
uh programmed because we'll just add to
uh the chaos we actually have to be
relaxed and awake instead of stressed
out and unconscious and we have the data
to show that when you're relaxed and
awake amazing things can actually happen
to you instead of in survival stressed
out and in a program so in order to
create out something new we got to be we
got to be in the present moment and we
have to be outside that pace of where
everything's moving very quickly and and
Technology unfortunately is causing
people it's causing people to think uh
uh instead of them for them to think on
their own and I'm concerned about that
because
um
I never tell people what to think I I
want them to think for themselves I
think it's really important for us to
think for ourselves so there's an
acceleration that's taking place
energetically but I do think that that
acceleration is really just endorsing uh
uh who who you're being so Master the
moment and and learn how to be a Creator
uh I think that amazing things happen
and that's exactly what we're
discovering over and over again and just
witnessing the the science
is absolutely supporting the that you
are greater than you think more powerful
than you know more and limited than you
can ever dream we have the data over and
over again that suggests that and the
testimonials that we have in hundreds of
people we have cancer researchers
standing on the stage with cancer
completely gone we see stage four
Cancers and bones and organs and liver
in the lungs com metastatic cancer just
doesn't typically go away
um very easily and out of the bones
there's no sign of it anywhere I mean
not once not twice over and over again
we had two people at an event that were
blind if your personality is made up of
how you think how you act and how you
feel and it is yes or no
and you stop thinking the same way and
nerve cells that no longer fire together
no longer wire together every place
where one neuron connects with another
neurons called the memory
so as you begin to on fire and unwire
you prune the very circuits in your
brain that are connected to the old self
and the memory
of the old self begins to mutate begins
to change so then you would say where
is that memory stored and it's stored in
the soul now
as wisdom because you're no longer that
person yes or no
and if you could no longer behave the
same way in nerve cells that no longer
fire together no longer wire together
and pruning is part of biology you don't
use it you lose it
then your memory of the old self would
begin to change and that is a biological
death in the beginning that is
uncomfortable for a lot of people
if you're no longer feeling the same
emotions that keep you connected to the
past and you keep inhibiting that
process the body will be craving the
chemicals in the beginning because it's
been conditioned that way it's been it's
been addicted it's the mind and it's
anticipating events and the emotions
from those events and you're putting the
brakes on
and that's uncomfortable and you got to
stay conscious and it takes an enormous
amount of energy and you're no longer
signaling the same genes and producing
the same hormones and your body is no
longer being influenced by your mind in
the same way
and sometimes the mind is the biggest
enemy to the body
and you're inhibiting that process
and the body which has become the Mind
wants its way
and it's uncomfortable to change and you
got to be able to be greater than that
to truly change and everybody that's
changed has come up against that feeling
and they almost make the same choice and
they don't and they're so glad that they
didn't
and it takes an enormous amount of
energy and awareness to do that so as
the old self
deconstructs because you have the free
will to decide who you want to be on a
moment-to-moment basis and if your life
isn't changing and you want to change
your life you got to change and now you
are playing the game and you are now
saying this personality
this person that I've become I'm in the
habit of being it and I want to become
somebody else
and the more you learn about love the
more you learn about life the more you
learn about possibility and potential
the more you become aware of it there
are more possibilities and knowledge is
the thing that gives us that
and so the old self
is a memory like another lifetime like
you can remember it but you're no longer
interested in it any longer because it
no longer defines you
how many people understand what I'm
talking about so then the biological
death of the old self is crossing a
river of change and you got to stay with
it long enough to become somebody else
and you think it's about well if it's
you think it's about health it's about
who you become
the people who become somebody else they
they see dramatic changes in their
health and in their lives
and and they can't find the words to be
able to explain it
but it's practical though if you truly
want to change your life you have to
change yourself you would have to be
conscious of your thoughts and aware of
your actions and and familiar with those
emotions and you would never fall from
grace and if you did you would stop and
self-correct if you truly were
interested in evolution and if you said
to me it's I lost it because of that
person
I'd say that you're back to the
unconscious program of allowing your
environment to control how you feel and
think you got two choices stay there
for another six hours or pause and
change your energy change your energy
and get back to the emotions of your
future and the feelings of your future
it's a much better place to be
reason this with me
you could have a great meditation and
condition your body just like you did
into the future
you come back to your senses and you
return back to the same old self romance
in the past again
you're going to weigh that one 50-minute
one hour meditation against the rest of
the day back to you
you got to start practicing we have to
start doing it with our eyes open and
the font of who we want to become should
produce the feeling of it
instantaneously in other words the
thought of your future should produce
the feeling that it already happened
instead of the feeling of lack because
it hasn't happened
how many people understand that and the
people who do this well they condition
their body into the future and they say
I don't know how it happened it's like
my body was led right to the event and
your body is going to follow your mind
to an unknown just like it follows your
mind to the toilet every morning but
instead of it being known it's going to
be the unknown
that's where your attention and your
energy has been
I'm telling you it doesn't matter what
you believe in doesn't matter the color
your skin what you eat I don't care it
doesn't matter I've seen it in all ways
so then the thought of our future if
we're doing this properly should produce
the feeling that it already happened
if the thought of your future produces
the lack that it hasn't happened you're
still in your past and nothing is going
to change
and it would make sense then that you
would want to get that heart open on a
regular basis so that you can feel the
emotions of your future before it
happens I'm telling you there's a lot of
biology that changes in you
and you do it enough times you become
that person
the thought of it then produces the
feeling that it's already happened
that's how you know you're getting close
independent of what's going on in your
life
that's when you're mastering yourself
and mastering your life I travel around
the world and I have the opportunity to
talk to all kinds of people and one of
the things that
independent of people's beliefs
political beliefs religious beliefs
whatever there seems to be a Common
Thread that people feel like something's
not right
and I think when
um you get to a point where you realize
that no health care plan no government
no religion is going to take care of you
know then who is going to take care of
you and the answer is you right
so my interest is to give people the
tools and the understanding that they
could heal their body that they could
create a better life for themselves
that they could overcome past traumas
and scars that were created even as
early as childhood that tend to be
unconscious programs that keep them
repeating the same you know scenarios in
their life
uh to teach people how to induce
mystical experiences so that it changes
the frame of what the way they look at
reality
and so what an amazing time in history
to be alive because Consciousness is
awareness
and awareness is paying attention and
paying attention is noticing so so if a
person lives a life as an example
and is diagnosed with a health condition
they're what they're conscious of
is just a certain number of choices that
they could make based on the past based
on tradition based on what's worked for
normal or natural
but what happens when that person has
done the chemotherapy has done the
surgery has done the radiation has done
the vegan diet has done the gluten-free
diet has done the ketogenic diet has
done all the things all the exercise
and they still have the same health
condition
yeah it begs the question
if our personality creates our personal
reality
and her personality is made up of how we
think how we act and how we feel
then the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life not their ex not their
parents not their culture they create
their life so the fundamental question
is if if
I want to change my life
then that means that I have to change or
nothing changes in my life until I
change right so the person who's done
all these treatments and still faced
with the health condition this is just
an example
all of a sudden says there's got to be
another way there's got to be something
else and so knowledge information
when we learn knowledge we learn
information we make new Connections in
our brain that's what learning is we're
forging synaptic connections
but that philosophical theoretical
intellectual information is void of
experience
someone who takes that knowledge and
applies it and personalizes demonstrates
it initiates that knowledge
is now interested in the truth of the
experience of that information
so the person then who becomes conscious
that they could actually heal themselves
by changing the way they think the way
they act the way they feel if I truly go
into the experiment of no longer
thinking the same way no longer acting
the same way no longer feeling the same
way and I start thinking about what
thoughts I do want to fire and wire in
my brain
and if I do it with intention and
attention I'll begin to install
neurological Hardware keep doing it and
becomes like a software program it
becomes a new voice in your head that
goes from I can't to I can
no magic there if you said how would
greatness live today how what would love
look like today what would be a greater
expression of myself in the things that
I do
turns out if you close your eyes and you
rehearse in your mind
how you're going to be
in any aspect of your day if you're
truly present the brain doesn't know the
difference between the inward experience
of what you're imagining and the outer
real experience it look the brain looks
like you've already done it the brain
looks like it's already experiencing now
do that enough times the hardware
becomes a software program and you start
behaving like a different person super
athletes do this this is musicians
athletes dancers everybody who's good at
something is always rehearsing in their
mind
that that rehearsal is just as important
as the physical demonstration it's
priming the brain because the brain is a
record of the past now you're actually
making it a map to the Future you're
installing circuits to use
if you said God I live my whole life in
guilt I didn't know it was guilt uh in
shame or unworthiness unself-doubt and
security fear and all of a sudden you're
looking at that emotion you understand
that emotion is actually down regulating
genes and creating disease you figure
that out you read about it makes sense
then all of the hatred all the anger all
the bitterness you have to someone or
something in your past
is keeping you connected to the past so
you'd say
can I teach my body emotionally
what a new future could feel like before
it happens not waiting for your wealth
to feel abundance or waiting for your
relationship to feel love or waiting for
your healing to feel gratitude that's
the old model of reality of cause and
effect this is about causing an effect
turns out if you can elevate your
emotional state
and you can sustain that emotional state
your body's so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating that
emotion
and that emotion that you're creating by
thought alone your body's actually
believing it's living in a new reality
in new environment now the environment
signals the gene the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion that person is actually
signaling genes ahead of the environment
genes make proteins and proteins are
responsible for the structure and
functional body the expression of
proteins is the expression of life okay
every day the person practices going
from the old self to the new cell this
is what's happening in the world right
now
as they start to change and they start
unfiring and unwiring and they stop
conditioning the body emotionally for
the past and practice this
they emerge as a new personality they
become somebody else and like magic
the diseases exists in the old person
and there's somebody else now here's
where Consciousness comes in
that person comes to a workshop and they
stand on the stage in front of 1500
people and they tell their story
and everybody in that audience is
leaning in
why because they're looking at truth
they're looking at the someone who just
got healed from a chronic uh chronic I'm
talking about stage four cancers I'm
talking about Parkinson's disease I'm
talking about rare genetic disorders
and now the person in the audience is
becoming conscious
of a possibility that they were once
unconscious to And when they see that's
possible it's a four minute mile I mean
four minute mile nobody thought anybody
could break a mile and under formulas
they said it was biological artificial
yeah physiologically impossible 1400
people have done it already so like this
is the four minute mile someone's
piercing through a limitation a level of
unconsciousness and now that's a
footprint in the quantum field but in
three-dimensional reality you're looking
at that person they look no different
than anybody else and the person says
if that person can do it I can do it as
well I think the ego is something that
is healthy when it's in Balance like if
I have a bonfire in my backyard and
those and the Flames are getting a
little bit too big and there's ashes and
sparks flying off the bonfire your ego
says David step back you know it's it's
preservational wants to take care of the
body if we're hiking on a cliff and we
come to a very narrow path and it's a
thousand foot drop your ego is going to
say stay close to the wall don't go out
to the edge you could be injured and be
hurt so the egos has a function to
really in a sense be analytical and and
weigh what we know against what we don't
know and it's healthy the problem is is
when it's driven by the hormones of
stress and stress is when your body's
knocked out of balance it's not that
knocked out of order that state actually
causes you to be altered and there'll
always be a gap between the way things
appear or the way you appear and the way
things really are you're in an altered
state now for the short term that's
great all organisms can tolerate that
but if you keep doing that for an
extended period of time the arousal
that's created from the stress hormones
actually causes the analytical mind all
of a sudden to go into overdrive so now
the endorsement of the ego becomes
enhanced and we become selfish that's
what it does it causes it causes us to
be self-indulgent to be self-centered to
be self-important to be
self-apprandizing to be full of
self-pity because in stress there's only
one thing that's important when you're
in survival and that's you and so all of
our attention goes on our body all of
our attention goes on all the elements
in our environment and we come become
very preoccupied with time now
when we're in balance
and there's order in the autonomic
nervous system there's health and if
stress is when you move out of balance
autonomic dysregulation then you are
altered from wholeness you are you are
separate from uh everyone and everything
in your life and you tend to trust less
it's not a time to open your heart in
the jungle the survival Gene is switched
on you don't communicate very well
you're looking at how you can get to
where you need to be or accomplish what
you need to do first and you got to be
there first and compete because this is
all driven by those stress hormones so
the ego becomes out of balance now
here's the cool part about all of this
when people are driven by those stress
hormones and they don't know how to
change it they don't know how to
self-regulate again it's not that you
react the question is how long are you
going to react if they don't know how to
do that the problem with most people is
they start analyzing their life
within the emotion that's disturbing
them now emotions are a record of the
past so what we see on brain scans over
and over again when you start over
analyzing and overthinking in a selfish
way
100 of the time you'll make your brain
worse and that will have dramatic
effects on your body so when the heart
is racing because it's pumping blood but
you're sitting in a zoom call and you're
smiling and you're looking at that
person a zoom calling you're thinking
about ways to murder them you're
producing those chemicals but you're not
running and you're not fighting and
you're not hiding so what happens is the
heart is pumping against a very closed
system and it moves out of order it
moves out of balance and now the
autonomic nervous system which controls
and coordinates all other systems in
your body
is at a balance in that dysregulation
causes disease so then the fundamental
question is okay can I trade fear can I
trade anger can I trade competition can
I trade frustration resentment in
patience hostility uh hopelessness
powerlessness Whatever anxiety for an
elevated emotion can I learn how to
dial down those stress hormones and
practice feeling elevated emotions turns
out
you can do that now the real question is
when you're in your heart you're not so
selfish in fact when there's a change in
blood flow to the heart and oxytocin and
nitric oxide is released you tend to
want to give you you tend to want to
consider the whole now you lead with
your heart
you're not separate from anybody you're
you're functioning as a community so I
think then that
um our future as as human beings is that
we have to be able to live in an
elevated state in our hearts and if we
fall from grace back into those survival
emotions the key is to be able to
self-regulate and get so good at it in
your meditation with your eyes closed so
good at it that you can do it with your
eyes open now that's when the game
becomes really really important so uh
when people do the work and they do
their meditations and they come up
against themselves gosh I want them to I
want them to come up against their fear
and in the in the week-long workshops I
want them to come up against their
impatience I want all those thoughts
that come up that say I can't it's too
hard I'll never change it's my ex's
fault it's my boss's fault I want those
thoughts to be right in their face and I
want to give them tools to let them know
that right on the other side of that
that thought right on the other side of
that propensity to want to get up and
quit right on the other side of that
emotion that's keeping them connected to
the past if they're willing to sit in
the fire
to sit with themselves and instead of
getting up and quitting on themselves
learn how to self-regulate and create
brain and heart coherence I guarantee
you every time they go a little further
and they produce those victories of
those victories add up so what's the
side effect of that you return back to
your life you don't need jerk as much
why because you just overcame some part
of your aggression and anger by sitting
with your body and like training an
animal
training a dog I don't know training the
servant to be present to to to to to to
be greater than the body as the mind to
execute a will that's greater than those
unconscious programs and what we found
out is when people actually apply some
type of formula to be able to do this
every time they bring the body back into
the present moment it starts liberating
energy
so there it goes the frustration there
goes the impatience and all of a sudden
the unknown which tends to be such a
scary place for most people it is the
present moment you see the side effect
of that as the person's more present
they're less preoccupied with all the
things that people spend most of their
attention on now so you overcome the ego
you overcome the personality uh uh
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
that you've got to be able to lay it
down
and as you temper your body and your
mind
um the ego tends to be less selfish and
more selfless and then the side effect
of that is that then if I say hey look
at David he's actually doing it I'm
going to try it too because he's he's
doing it and researching neurosciences
you hang out with people that do things
you start your brain synchronizes and
you start doing those same things it's
called an emergence emergence that's the
birds all moving in the same direction
it's a school of fish moving is one mind
and one heart if you study that you
think there's one leader like that
everybody's following a leader like a
top-down phenomenon it's actually wrong
it's a bottom-up phenomenon everybody's
leading so the way we change the world
then is that you work on yourself I'll
work on myself we get to show up and
bring our best and when we're not at our
best we excuse ourselves get back to
that state and we present ourselves back
to the world and I think this is such a
great time in history where people
really need some tools to be able to
cope with with all the challenges in the
world
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for five
hours of Joe dispenza motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there the only way you can
do that is you have to learn how to take
all of your attention off your body and
become a nobody take all of your
attention off all the people in your
life that you give so much of your
attention and energy to because you have
an emotion associated with